a flurry of diplomatic activity as the
us seeks to emphasize its commitment to
the security of the asia pacific
no region will do more to set the
trajectory of the 21st century than this
one
the defense secretary lloyd austin held
talks with several peers from asian
countries during his visit to singapore
including his chinese counterpart
general wei funghu
at what's called the shangri-la dialogue
austin told delegates chinese military
activity around taiwan is a threat to
the region we remain focused on
maintaining peace
stability and the status quo
across across the taiwan strait
but the prc's moves
threaten to undermine security and
stability
and prosperity in the indo-pacific we've
seen allies analysts say the defense
chief's speech underscored major
differences between the u.s and china
secretary of state mentioned a lot about
the international
order especially the rule-based order i
think for the chinese question is whose
roots and whose order more than a dozen
defense chiefs from around the world are
in singapore for the security summit
that's considered the most important in
asia with regional stability on the
agenda defense chiefs stepped up to
share their vision for the asia pacific
while lloyd austin's speech was the main
event of the day other speeches also
caught the attention of attendees
managing including one by indonesia's
defense chief prabowo subianto we have
come
to our own
the ancient way
of resolving
these
challenges i think the chinese like that
message very much because it uh goes in
line with the chinese positions that
asia is asians asia subianto told al
jazeera his country and many others
don't want to take sides the united
states
have helped us many many times
in our in our critical
moments
but china
also
china has also
helped us china has also defended us
thank you very much
officials from the five power defense
arrangements pact also met on the
summit's sidelines
the defence ministers of malaysia
singapore new zealand australia and the
uk say the historic pact has modern
relevance in the face of tensions in the
region a world where there are pretty
complex strategic challenges
china's defence minister will address
the summit on sunday in a speech that's
expected to outline beijing's vision for
meeting those challenges jessica
washington al jazeera singapore